4k TVs are more affordable than ever if
you're thinking of buying one make sure
that it's more future proof by getting
one that supports HDR as it can
significantly bolster your gaming and
entertainment experience there's no
doubt that watching 4k content can look
really crisp but having access to a
panel that can produce more realistic
and divid colors is arguably more
important that's where HDR comes into
play
HDR tvs uses displays that offer a much
wider color gamut compared to the
standard RGB panels we've been
accustomed to for so long modern
consoles like the PlayStation 4 and Xbox
one X support HDR games like Gears of
War 4 are able to feature deeper black
levels and games like infamous second
son are able to portray a more realistic
Sun shaft and godrays you also get more
accurate colors in general while HDR
content is still in an early state many
of the new blockbuster releases feature
4k HDR blu-rays and streaming sites like
Netflix and Amazon Prime a rolling a 4k
HDR content according to Nvidia
compared to srgb HDR can expand the
color gamut by a factor of two which
makes up roughly 75 percent of the
visible color spectrum it allows colors
to provide more granularity so you can
get tones that are more subtle or
vibrant watching content like planet
Earth 2 exemplifies how video can look
much more colorful and lifelike with HDR
enabled many new high-end TVs are now
bundling 4k and HDR together but there
are several that don't so it's important
to check to see if the respective TV you
want to buy supports the feature any TVs
that brandish the Ultra HD premium label
will support both 4k and HDR there are
three major standards Dolby vision HDR
10 and HL g our sister sites CNET
suggests that dolby vision tends to look
the best on average but dolby does
charge TV manufacturers a licensing fee
to use the tech which could be passed
down to you the consumer at any rate any
HDR TV will look better than an sRGB
equivalent one good affordable option we
recommend is TCL's 55 p 605 you can
typically find it online for around 600
bucks and it comes with dolby vision HDR
if you want to go the extra mile you
could opt to get a 4k HDR oled TV which
will offer true
since they don't use traditional LEDs
and instead up to use individually
backlit pixels however while OLED panels
are certainly nice they generally cost a
lot more and are thus relegated in the
nice-to-haves category but when it comes
to HDR the slight premium you might pay
is worth it considering it will be
another prominent display standard
moving forward in the end if you're
gonna spend hundreds of dollars to
purchase a nice 4k TV it might as well
make sure it's more future proof by
ensuring it supports HDR for more
information on how HDR FX games make
sure to check out our pc graphics
settings explainer video thanks for
watching